it is a great honor to welcome you here
in the German bundestag
ment houses
on behalf of the entire
Parliament we would like to welcome you
your majesty
being consort into your entire
delegation
and Mr Wolf as two of our former Federal
presidents
I would also like to welcome four former
presidents of the bundesters
a warm welcome to YouTube
so many high-ranking guests uh we are
underlining the importance of
anglo-german relations spoke here
um before this house as the Prince of
Wales during the Remembrance Day back in
2020. today you speak as king and as a
representative of one of the oldest
democracies in the world
have a special
um foreign
into Manchester to keep it safe and with
us reserved or
eternity this is just a small episode
from our joint history
during the 20th century it was a history
of extremes Great Britain
a significant contribution to freeing
Western Europe from national socialism
1938 Great Britain received thousands of
Jewish children often the only ones who
survived in their family
at Liverpool Street a monument which
reminds us of this act of humanity
during my visit in Great Britain a few
weeks ago I met some of those who were
saved it deeply moved me I'm fine
Association
that looks after and the memory and that
wisdom also in charge of
um children being saved home will come
to you
a supported integrating Germany into the
Western World and promoted democracy the
first guest at bundestag was the Speaker
of the House of Commons Arthur woodborne
in his speech recommended to his
colleagues in Germany
you should never forget that
foreign
British culture and the British way of
living and with great respect we
remember your mother during her lifetime
Queen Elizabeth II
for reconciliation between our countries
together with your father Prince Philip
she visited Germany she visited
Great Britain and Germany remain close
allies and trusted partners
also after the British decision to leave
the EU
people in our
countries are connected due to cultural
exchanges due to travel and uh
parliamentary fascination
our parliaments enjoy very close
contacts our governments operate closely
in many organizations and in many
different formats Great Britain enter
Germany
we are in solidarity with Ukraine in
their fight or freedom and
self-determination we fight for common
values and uh
[Music]
that when it comes to
existential tasks that you have been
fighting for a long time and that is the
fight against the climate change and the
preservation of our values and our basis
for living
a joint responsibility for the future is
something you underlined three years ago
during Remembrance Day 2020 he said
together
we uh
an inevitable Force for the good in the
world and nowadays we need this power
this is strength more than ever the
Majesty the floor is yours
president
yeah president
bundestags presidential dear president
ladies and gentlemen
it is a great honor for me to be here
with you today
for us it is very important that during
our first visit as king we had been
invited to Germany and above all
that I'm able to speak here today
to renew our bond of friendship
the skipped come an ambassador
there is partly a better place for this
commitment than this building
the Stone's office
tell the story of our history it tells
of what
watch their politicians at work it is
live democracy my wife and I in November
in November 2020
opportunity to be here
on the occasion of the Remembrance Day
for me it was very important 75 years
after
the second world war
to be here together
and to commemorate the victims
the first member of my family I was able
to participate in this moving
commemorative events
United Kingdom and Germany on the past
of Germany and on a
paths president
impressively in the 2000s
by participating in the commemoration
today end of the first world war in
London
to be with you once again
now is King
and to renew the special bond of
friendship between our two countries
this friendship meant so much to my
beloved mother the late Queen
who often spoke of the 15 official
visits she made Germany including her
five State visits
the first of those in
1965 came when our continent was still
deeply scarred by War and the trauma of
conflict
hers was the wartime generation and like
my father the queen had served in
uniform
that my parents 11-day tour of Germany
should prove to be a pivotal moment in
the reconciliation between our Nations
was therefore a matter of great personal
significance to them both
of Worcester
in Deutschland
she visited German very often and wanted
to make her contribution perhaps that is
the reason why
she has gained such a valuable heart in
the hearts of Germans
my family
and I were deeply blazed by the reaction
of Germany after the death
the entries in the book of condolences
from right across the country
of that in our times
consolation on behalf of my entire
family I would like to thank you from
the bottom of my heart until now
Dimension the Deep sympathy
sympathies by the people from Germany Mr
President
Madam president
this is my last visit since I've spoken
here last this caught off their own war
is back in Europe the war of a question
against Ukraine is laid Uber services
so many lives are being destroyed
freedom and dignity are trampled on the
foot away
is as threatened as are our Democratic
Values
the world is not looking on without
being active
we are deeply shocked by the destruction
but we can
be encouraged by our Unity when it comes
to
defending Ukraine
Peace and Freedom
Deutschland
Germany and United Kingdoms
I've taken on an important role as
Leaders as the biggest European donors
too Ukraine
we have given money and we've taken the
decisions that might have been
unimaginable some time ago Germany's
decisions
such Military Support to Ukraine is
considered to be a very welcome and very
important
by the world of love
[Applause]
foreign
Germany is the only country
worldwide
United Kingdom
has such a joint unit and this is a
clear
example and clear evidence for our
partnership ladies and gentlemen what
did I feel in the strength of the
partnership between our two countries
Germany her people and distinctive
culture have made such a profound impact
on me over so many years so many of my
previous visits
since I first came to Germany
when I was just 13.
years old I have grown to become
familiar with the different corners of
this remarkable land
like many British people I have close
personal ties here
in my case cherished family
relationships and associations that go
back Generations
for all of us however
there are countless points of connection
and common experience in the British
German story
which has unfolded over nearly two
millennium
throughout the Middle Ages the renowned
Hanseatic League traded goods from
Lubeck and Hamburg to Ports up and down
the English Coast
establishing a trading partnership which
underpins our shared prosperity to this
day
where Goods traveled ideas traveled too
however people came to be inspired by
each other's examples
the first language into which
Shakespeare was translated and the first
Shakespeare Society in
1864 was not founded in the UK no in
Weimar in Germany
[Applause]
during the coronation in Westminster
Abbey we will again hear great words
born
as a German and died as a British
coronation
the second in
1727. you've been hearing this music
throughout the centuries between our
lands
in the 19th century many britons fell in
love with Germany whilst on the ground
tour
William Turner's mesmerizing paintings
of the Rhine
sparked in his countrymen the ambition
to see those landscapes for themselves
a demand later met by Thomas Cook the
pioneer of Tourism
who would organize his first foreign
trip along the Rhine
stops at cologne Frankfurt Heidelberg
and badenburg
today millions of britons visit Germany
each year just as millions of Germans
traveled to our Shores
britons come to admire
Berlin's vibrant culture and nightlife
making up Europe's largest visitor group
to this wonderful City
so we are still
admire
of each other's culture
dependent upon each other's economies
and inspired by each other's ideas
more recent Generations may think as
readily of The Beatles or craftwork
as they do of Brahms or Baron but the
web of cultural connections is as strong
as ever
and perhaps most importantly for the
last 50 years we have loved together
both at each other and with each other
and while miss Sophie's the same
procedures every year James
and while that does not I hope give a
very accurate impression of modern
Britain
it is I know an integral part of a
German Happy New Year
in Britain Germany's comedy Ambassador
Henning then has given us an
understanding of German quirks as Monty
Python brought around here
and
like all old friends at moments the
warmth of our relationship allows a
small smile at each other's expense
especially the matches between our
football team
[Applause]
s
for this background it was something
very special that uh
European champion
Hebert and Sport Lincoln a volcanized
haban by the Manchester
that is
the quality of the sections and in doing
so they have inspired a whole generation
above and beyond sporting achievements
Deutschland Great Britain and Germany
and the whole world one example this is
just one example of how our countries
together
there are I am delighted to say very
many more
faced with so many shared challenges the
United Kingdom and Germany are together
providing leadership to secure our
shared future
today the United Kingdom in Germany are
Europe's two largest producers of power
from offshore wind
many German firms are involved in the
production and erection of turbines off
the British Coast
the North Sea across which our people
have traveled
and traded for Generations is soon to be
the site of a new interconnector
allowing us directly to trade
electricity
our countries are both accelerating the
expansion of our hydrogen economies
few which could transform our future
and I'm looking forward to seeing
hamburg's plans to use hydrogen in its
efforts to become a fully sustainable
port
innovation
these Innovations are Viking in
combating the existential challenge of
climate change and global warming which
confronts us all
and as such I was delighted to meet
participants of the Berlin energy
transition dialogue yesterday
to hear how countries are accelerating
this transition
foreign
in Berlin
full electrician Londoner Taxi
can be driven through the city in a
fully electric London taxi at the
international level we are after working
very closely together during the climate
conference in Glasgow together with a
South Africa we set up the uh I'm
innovated a circle Just Energy
transitioned partnership and another
partnership with Indonesia with the
result of a very close the corporation
during a Germany's presidency of seven
Mr President ladies and gentlemen
this is Central partnership between our
two countries he's built
of the expertise dedication
and Ingenuity of countless people in
both Germany and the United Kingdom
to them all I could only offer my
sincere and heartfelt gratitude
tomorrow we will once again stand with
the people of Germany in solemn
remembrance
in Hamburg I will pay my respects at the
memorial to the Kinder transport which
85 years ago saved the lives of more
than ten thousand Jewish children from
Nazism and gave them safe passage to new
lives in Britain
foreign
in Remembering those who perished in the
Allied bombing of Hamburg in 1943
from the past
ORS
through our commitment for a joint
future
can we fulfill our destiny together
and we need to stand up for our values
with resolution
enable our people to live in peace and
prosperity a life that they deserve
history of our two countries it still
has many Unwritten chapters
let us
start writings
chapters in our efforts for a better
future
and the promise of our adjoined future
require
from us no less than that
ladies and gentlemen oh thank you very
much for your attention
what a pretty wide-rating speech by the
king bear to the buddhistag he was
introduced by the president of the
Brunswick barbell bass
welcoming him and thanking Great Britain
for being a friend to Germany also both
of them pointing out the Norman Foster
designed the Glorious building that they
are standing in and speaking and you can
see they're a standing ovation from the
members of the bundestag
the king talking in both German and
English and speaking very warmly of the
relationship between Germany and the UK
talking about his own personal links to
Germany his family clearly his strong
grasp of the language but also talking
about the things that that we share
um sense of humor music name checking
the Beatles along with craft work
talking about Turners painting of the
Rhine even referencing Dinner for One
the English program comedy program that
many Germans watch on New Year's Eve
also talking about the football the
lionesses beating Germany for the
European championship and talking about
the equality of sexes and how they've
inspired a whole generation and the
world but also perhaps more importantly
talking about politics talking about the
war of aggression in Ukraine as he
dubbed it so many lives being destroyed
and the importance of security in Europe
how that is threatened along with our
values and praise Germany's decision to
provide Provide support to Ukraine
calling it important and welcome and
also talking about the war learning from
the past and how it is our first duty
but only with commitment to each other
he says can we fulfill our destiny in
the future and mentioning how tomorrow
he will be in Hamburg that marking both
the memorial to those 10 000 Jewish
children who are saved from Nazism by
the kindest transport but also
remembering those who perished in the
Allied bombing of Hamburg in
1943. let's bring in our Royal
correspondent Laura bundock who was
there listening in to that Laura what
are your Reflections on this speech
I think this is a speech focusing
entirely on the connections the bonds
the alliances between Germany and
Britain the way the two countries have
obec history historically been connected
via all the way back to cultural ties
training links hundreds of years ago to
now to where we are now be it through
music
um be it through culture one key thing I
think which was so interesting is this
speech made absolutely no mention to
brexit whatsoever this is a speech that
is looking ahead right to the Future and
remember this state visit was set up
um as I say these things always are a
deployment on behalf of the government
to strengthen the relations in this
post-brexit age after so many years of
Divisions from brexit this was the
monarchy being deployed to use its soft
power as much as it can and to show
Europe to show Germany of course it was
supposed to be France's rather to show
Germany now just how much that Alliance
is valued and important that is
interesting hearing the king talking
about war in Ukraine and how both
Germany and Britain have been leading
the way in terms of the efforts to
support uh Ukraine be it through taking
in ukrainians albeit through the
military support the financial support
that's been offered but this was a
speech focusing on the future looking
ahead at how that relationship those
bonds mean a lot to Britain and how they
in the future will continue uh to me a
lot but no mention that as I say of
brexit not even a passing word
and or before the speech we're just
looking at some of the images of it now
they had a public walkabout and and
quite a warm reception it seemed from
those on the streets
yeah
in yesterday's game and the king and
queen console survive the Brandenburg
gate for the very Grand the ceremonial
welcome and honor that has only ever
been given to the King as a visiting
head of state there were crowds there
but they were small and they were
hand-picked these were people who are
being asked to go there so this was the
first time coming to the farmers market
this weekly farmers market that members
of the public could actually get close
to the couple and I think you do get a
sense that there is perhaps we don't
appreciate it much there's such more
infinitely here in Germany uh with the
British royal family much of that I
think and the King mentioned it in
speech it goes back to between many
visits here she made five official state
visits here she visited officially on
other occasions as well so I think her
visit in 1965 to West Germany it was
seen as the king reference in the
speeches pivotal moment when it came to
the international World reconciling with
with Germany West Germany at the time
and the pride as he said that the Queen
and Princess always felt they had and
being able to be part of that moment was
something that meant a lot and I think
people in Germany appreciate the
gestures over the year many years over
the last 50 years made by the royal
family and of course don't forget the
genetic links as well and members of the
king's distant family from his father's
side paints that state banquet last
night so there there are other Royal
links there but very much there is a
sense of not only respect following the
queen
um but there is an affinity I think
there is an affinity with the German
people and we saw that at the market
today and there are other engagements
coming up this afternoon reflecting the
interest of both the king and the queen
consort but I think it was it an
interesting moment this morning seeing
the public as they've walked through
through that farmers market
Laura thanks very much for that so far
let's talk now to Sophia Gaston who's
head of foreign policy and UK resilience
at policy exchange Sophia good to talk
to you too how we've talked a little bit
about about Prince Charles and how
important this visit is to him but how
important would you say it is to Germany
as well that that the King's first
visitors head of state is is to that
country
hugely important I mean I don't think we
can underestimate the significance of
this visit it's significant for the king
of course this is his first official
state visit but it's also really a
broader signal from the UK around a
recalibration of our relationship with
the EU with European capitals and us
moving into a new much more kind of
confident I think pragmatic uh
relationship there and I think really
the war in Ukraine has played an
enormous role in this and of course
Germany has been going through a quite
significant shift in its uh security and
defense policy as a result of this and I
think because the UK has been such an
important actor in Ukraine and has
really won the soft power benefits of
our investments there I think for a
country like Germany that's sort of
finding its feet as a security actor
this is a huge uh stamp of approval and
a source of encouragement to say We
Stand alongside you and we see each
other as equal partners
visiting East Germany this morning as
well and then going on to Hamburg this
afternoon and and talking about Kinder
transport but also looking at memory
remembering those who died during the
war
um not shying away in his speech from
from the difficult relationship that
there has been in the past between
Germany and the UK
I think the theme Here is around the
juxtaposition of history in the future
there's this idea of an inflection point
I think Charles giving that speech there
in the reichstag building as he noted
designed by British architect Norman
Foster who really had to take a sort of
shell very damaged but extremely
symbolic building and build something
new that's respected the past but
brought it into the future I think the
message here from Charles is that we
have to understand the past and that we
shouldn't be brushing that aside even if
that means difficult conversations but
also that we must not be constrained by
it and I think for a country like
Germany that is starting to have to
reconcile with the culture that
developed post-war in understanding its
security role in Europe
starting to sort of free itself from the
shackles of that and understanding that
the moment here with a land war in New
in Europe on you know on on our Shores
um that it really has to look to the
Future and and come into its confidence
um so I think that Charles is really
trying to send a message there of
encouragement to say come on we're with
you and this is not a zero-sum game you
can respect the past you can acknowledge
that but you can also move briefly
forward into a new chapter
and that message to Germany from from
the King also will be heard by wider
Europe won't it what do you think the
reaction will be on a wider sense and
also perhaps in Russia as well
important that this visit has come after
uh the Prime Minister which is two next
visit to France of course there was a
big Summit a few weeks ago where a sunak
and macron really broke bread they got
some solid policy outcomes there but
there was also just you know a sense of
Good Will being re-established there so
for the UK now to have had a head of
state and our prime minister visiting
the two big European capitals there I
think this is a real show of unity
Across the Western Alliance and
particularly in Europe to say
post-brexit yes we've left the EU but we
still have a real sense of not just a
partnership in kind of practical terms
but there's a strength of feeling here
we are one we are together and we're
standing absolutely United against
Russia's shocking invasion of Ukraine
severe Gaston ahead of foreign policy
and UK resilience at policy exchange
thank you very much